these days green-screen is easy you get
your lighting right to you point a
camera at someone and then you click a
few buttons and tweak a few settings in
your graphics software and there you go
perfect but how do they do this sort of
compositing before computers well there
are two answers to that one for film and
one for video and before anyone gets
pedantic I am summarizing here and
skipping over some early efforts and
dead ends but first let's talk about
film actual bulky reels of film you've
got no pixels to deal with here it's all
chemical processors all light hitting
bits of photosensitive real stuff 24
times a second if you go wrong you can't
leave Ray's and restart that film is
used up John go buy some more
anyway the earliest method for this sort
of effect involved filming an actor
against black and then making copies of
that film with higher and higher and
higher contrast until you had a simple
mapped with that you could pull off a
double exposure using chemical trickery
and something called an optical printer
to leave her a hole in the background
picture where the actor could then be
slotted in or partly actor if we talked
about Claude Rains as the Invisible Man
right variations on that high contrast
technique were used for decades
the next major breakthrough was the
travelling Matt the cloudless version
this was brought up by Disney who owned
the only camera in the world that could
pull it off
they let the actors normally but put
them in front of a white background
liquid sodium vapour lights
orange streetlights sodium light is
monochromatic but one very specific
wavelength something fancy optics you
could simultaneously record onto one
piece of film that would mostly ignore
that light another bit of film that only
reacted to that light presto a
near-perfect traveling matte even for
semi-transparent objects like Mary
Poppins is hat blue screen and green
screen on analog film work much the same
way they use filters to block out
particular colors and map them and then
they're carefully combined with an
optical printer then of course computers
came along and made the whole thing
easier but how about television
computers arrived earlier than you might
think they're the BBC use a bit of kit
called the quant L pink box for Doctor
Who as early as in 1980
but before that video was entirely about
electrical signals from a scanning
camera sensor if it was recorded those
signals would just be put straight on
magnetic tape there's no film to play
about with that but what you can do with
electronic signals is combine them and
build circuits that basically do analog
maths on them adding two signals
together or just fading between them was
mastered early in the days of
black-and-white TV now in color came
along you have red green and blue
signals although they weren't
transmitted over the air like that for
backwards compatibility it's a long and
overly complicated story but you can
make a system that would watch the
signal and when it hit a particular
color the color you wanted it would
switch out that signal with your
background and generally this was done
live on set there evil attempts to do
moving shots by rigging up really
complicated gearing arrangements to sync
the movements of two cameras one
pointing at actors on a blue screen one
point to get a model Klayton worked
sometimes no pixels no memory or hard
drives no ability to just tweak your
settings and try something else
if it didn't work when you did the best
you could because every day in the
studio cost an incredible amount of
money and the time of at least half a
dozen technicians and then of course
computers came along and made all of
that obsolete to the point where some
jerk with a laptop and a copy of After
Effects can make this video in an
afternoon
you